ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรค่ะ
วันนี้ใช่วันพุธค่ะเสียงหายนะผู้หญิงวัน
นี้วันพุธเป็นอะไรหายไปเลยเนาะวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่ 17
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
สิงหาคม
ปีพศอะไรคะปีพต 2  5  6 ห้า
ปีคศอะไรคะปีธอส.
2022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 26 เดือน
เดือน
สิงหาคมปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2565  a คศ
ปีพตต
2022 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วัน
พฤหัสบดี
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
18 เดือน
เดือน
สิงหาคมปีพตต
ปีพตต
256 หน้าปีคศ
ปีพศ.
2022 ห่างค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลาอ.วัดสิงห์
ไม่ได้ถามเดือนถามเวลา
ตอนนี้เวลา 11:00 น
11 โมงกี่นาที
11:06 ค่ะ
ไม่มีเวลาตี 1 ตี 2 แล้วเหรอเค้าตอนนี้
ตอนอื่น 5
11:06
หญิงกินข้าวหรอ
กูสาของผู้หญิงเนี่ย
เที่ยงคืนแล้วอ่ะ
ผู้หญิงที่คืนแล้วผู้หญิง 24
เพียงคืนแล้วเที่ยงคืนแล้วผู้หญิงไม่นอน
หรอก็ไปนอนก็ได้ค่ะ
ไม่นอนนั้น
โอเคไหมควายเดี๋ยววีดีโอนี้ผู้ขออยู่คน
เดียวแล้วกูหญิงจะไปนอนแล้วจะเล่าเรื่อง
ผี
ไม่ได้เล่าเรื่องผีจะพูดถึงไม่นอนนะเรา
เนี่ยต้องนอนทุกวันสมัยมันเป็นสิ่งที่แบบ
ว่าทุกวันทุกวันทุกวันเนี่ยเราก็นอนมี
เวลานอน
นอนเสร็จตื่นนอนมาอาบน้ำแปรงฟัน
กินข้าวำยานกินข้าวเอางานในบ้าน
กินข้าว
กินข้าวอาบน้ำนอนตื่นนอนเหมือนเดิมทุกวัน
ทุกวันทุกวัน
แล้ว
บางวันมันจะเปลี่ยนได้ใช่มั้ยวันไหนลง
วันเสาร์ว่าจะไม่ไปทำงานไงวันเสาร์ก็ตื่น
มาอาบน้ำ
อาบน้ำหาอาบน้ำอาบน้ำกินข้าว
เล่นเกม
เล่นเกมเล่นเกม in ข้าวเล่นเกมเล่นเกมกิน
ข้าวเดี๋ยววันเสาร์ไปไหนว่าอะไรเลยหรอ
วันเสาร์ทำอะไรอ่ะคุณฝากโอเคไหมถ้าทุกวัน
ของครูฟ้าจะเป็นตื่นนอนมามากินข้าวเล่น
เกมเล่นเกมกินข้าวเล่นเกมเล่นเกมแล้วก็
นอนแล้วก็ตื่นนอนมากินข้าวเล่นเกมเล่นเกม
มันก็เบื่อไหมผู้หญิง
ชอบเล่นเกมไงหนูก็ชอบเล่นเกมใช่ค่ะเห้ย
มันจะโอเคไหมอ่ะ
ไม่รู้เพราะว่าวันนี้เนี่ยผู้หญิงก็มีคำ
ถามมาถามฟ้าอีกแล้วนะคะผู้หญิงมีซ้ำถามมา
ถามกูหน้าม้าคำถามอะไรคะผู้หญิงถามอะไร
ถามผู้หญิงเนี่ยถามครูฟ้าว่าถ้าครูฟ้า
เนี่ยต้องใช้ชีวิตทุกวันทุกวันทุกวันทุก
วันเนี่ยเหมือนเดิม
คือเหมือนเดิมทุกวันทุกวันทุกวันนะไปตลอด
เลยอ้ะตั้งแต่ตอนนี้ใช่ไหมตอนนี้ปี 2022
อ่ะบวกให้ครูฟ้าไปอีกซักผ้า 10 ปี
จนถึง 2,000 บาท
72 อย่างเนี้ย
ทุกวันทุกวันทุกวันครูฟ้าต้องใช้ชีวิต
เหมือนเดิม
ไม่ได้ถามว่าโอเคไหมนะแต่จะถามว่า
ชีวิตเหมือนเดิมของครูฟ้าทุกวันเนี่ยมัน
จะเป็นยังไง
กูเป็นขอให้มันเป็นยังไง
อุ้ยกูมาคิดเองได้หรอผู้หญิงได้ค่ะได้ค่ะ
กูฟ้าอาทิตย์ได้เลยว่าชีวิตที่มันจะ
เหมือนเดิมแต่มันจะเหมือนเดิมไปทุกวันทุก
วันเลยไงแต่หนูมาคิดได้ว่ากูบ้าอย่างให้
วันนั้นน่ะวันที่มันจะเหมือนเดิมเนี่ยมัน
เป็นยังไง
อยากให้เป็นยังไง
ก็คิดเองนะอ้ากุมภาต้องมีชีวิตนะทุกวัน
ทุกวันเหมือนเดิม
อยากให้
ครูฟ้าน่าจะตื่นประมาณ
8 ซ้อมบอกบอกเวลาได้
ก็คิดว่าแปะๆ
8:00 น
ตื่นตื่น 08:00 นนะครับ
แล้วก็ประภาจะจะ
ทำอะไรก็ถึงนะตื่น 08:00 นแล้วก็จะอาบน้ำ
อาบน้ำน่าอาบน้ำอาบน้ำแปรงฟัน
นะผมด้วยหัวอยากสระผมตอนเช้านะคะทุกวัน
แล้วก็ฟ้าจะไปหาแมวเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยเธอจะไป
หาแมวกูว่าจะเป็นเล่นกับแมวหรอ
ใช่ว่าจะเอาอาหารไปให้แมวแล้วพ่อแม่กูก็
ต้องกินข้าว
แมวก็ต้องกินข้าวนะคะแล้วก็ไปหาแมว
แล้วก็เอาข้าวให้แมวกินแล้วก็มาก็จะกิน
อาหารเช้ากับแมวเราก็จะกิน
กิน
ไม่กินแมวนะด
เด็กกินว่าจะได้กินข้าวกับแมวให้เขาจะ
นั่งกินข้าวแมวแล้วถ้ากูฟ้าต้องเลือก
อาหารที่กินทุกวัน
ครูบาจะกิน
อันนี้เดียว
ไม่ครูหญิงพูดแบบนี้ได้ไงเรา
ไม่ใช่หรอ
ตอนเช้าเนี่ย
ควรจะกินอันนี้ค่ะ
อ๋อข้าวเหนียวหมูปิ้งวันนี้เค้าเหนียว
เรียนเดี๋ยวตอนนี้หมูปิ้ง
ข้าวเหนียวหมูปิ้งหานักเรียนต้องกินทุก
วันเหมือนกันใช่ไหมเหมือนเดิมจะกินข้าว
เหนียวหมูปิ้งนะฮะแล้วก็
เสร็จแล้วเนี่ยก็น่าจะถึงประมาณ
9:30 น
แล้วกูฟ้าจะทำอะไรต่อก็อยากให้วันนั้นน่ะ
หลังจากนั้นทำเป็นยังไง
พ่อแล้วก็โมงครึ่งเนี่ยก็คิดว่าน่าจะ
ประมาณ
10 โมง 11 โมง
น10โลว่ากินข้าวเสร็จแล้วจะ 10:00 นนะคะ
10 โมงเนี่ย
10:00 ครูฟ้าก็จะ
ตอนเช้าไปคิดว่าน่าจะอ่านหนังสือ
เพราะอยากอ่านหนังสือนะคะถึงแม้ว่าขี้
เกียจค่ะแต่ก็และไม่พบกันต้องไปแบบนี้ทุก
วันไงอ้าว่าจะอ่านหนังสือว่าจะได้
บังคับตัวเองให้อ่านหนังสือคือว่าจะ
พยายามโฟกัสนะคะในการอ่านหนังสือทุกวัน
เดี๋ยวก็อยากอ่านหนังสืออ่านหนังสืออ่าน
หนังสืออ่านหนังสือ
เวลาอ่านหนังสือ
อ่านหนังสืออยู่ถึงเที่ยง
หนู 2 ชั่วโมงใช่สองชั่วโมงน่าจะใช้เวลา
อ่านหนังสือ 2 ชั่วโมงพ่อเที่ยงแล้วกิน
อีกแล้วหรอคะ
คิดว่าเวลา 12:00 นกูก็อาจจะ
หยิบโทรศัพท์ขึ้นมาเช็คโซเชียลก่อนเนาะก็
จะเล่นโทรศัพท์เช็ค Social  Media
Twitter  Facebook
Instagram
อยู่ยะจนถึง
เล่นโทรศัพท์จนถึง 12:30 นค่ะ
แล้วก็จะกินข้าวค่ะคุณหญิง
[เพลง]
กินอะไรคะ
คิดว่า
กิน
อันนี้กูฟ้าเลือกแบบเฉพาะมากเลยอ่ะอ่ะ
หรือไม่ก็กินข้าวเหนียวหมูปิ้ง
ว่า
ก็ได้แล้วโครงฟ้าอาจจะกินเหมือนเดิม
ฮัลโหลหนูต้องกินทุกวันเขาก็จะเลือกไว้ไง
แล้วก็คือฟ้าจะกินตอนกลางวันเนี่ยนี้ฮะ
กระเพราครึ่งอ่า
เงี้ยผัดกระเพรากุ้งนักเรียนเห็นไหมประชด
ใช่อ่ากินผัดกระเพรากุ้งนาก็จะกินข้าวถึง
ประมาณเพราะเวลาฟ้ากินข้าวเนี่ยกูก็จะมี
ไอแพดแล้วก็จะดูเน็ตฟลิกซ์ด้วยนะคะเล็ก
เดี๋ยวเราจะกินข้าวถึงประมาณ
13:00 น
นากินข้าวแล้วตั้งแต่ 12:30 นถึง
13:30 นค่ะก็ประมาณ 1 ชั่วโมงกินข้าววัน
ของงมะหาที่กินข้าวซะแล้วกูฟ้าก็จะ
13:30 นทำไมตอนนี้นะ
[เพลง]
01:30 หรอบ่ายโมงครึ่งเนี่ย
ฝาจะให้ตอนช่วงบ่ายเป็นยังไงกูมาว่าจะไป
คาเฟ่
ไปร้านกาแฟมีร้านกาแฟประมาณบ่ายโมงครึ่ง
หนึ่งว่าจะไปร้านกาแฟหน้าร้านกาแฟ
[เพลง]
ร้านกาแฟ
น้ำสักที่หนึ่งที่น่ารักๆเป็นคาเฟ่เนาะ
มหานะก็
ฟ้าเนี่ยน่าจะไปวาดรูป
มี iPad  WiFi
iPad แล้วก็ไปวาดรูปที่ร้านคุณแม่ค่ะฮือ
ฮือ
ร้านกาแฟนะคะซักจนถึง
3:00 น
ก็ประมาณ 1 ชั่วโมงครึ่ง
จะถึงบ่าย 3 โมงใช่
แล้วก็บ่าย 3 โมงเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยครูพักก็
จะกลับบ้านค่ะกลับบ้าน 5 กลับบ้าน
กลับบ้านไปแล้วก็ดูซีรีส์
กับว่างไปดูซีรีส์กับคุณแม่ด้วยนะคะว่า
ชอบเพลงนี้ค่ะคุณแม่บ่าย 15:00 นดูเน็ต
ฟลิกซ์
viu  Disney  Plus เอชบีโอระยะดูซีรีส์
นะคะอยู่ซีรีส์กับคุณแม่จนถึง
18:00 น
3 ชั่วโมง
The  basic มากเลยนะ 18:00 นเนี่ยกูมาก็
จะออกไปหาแมวค่ะ
แมวตอนเย็นก็ต้องไปหาแมวตายห่านี่กูเข้า
ไปหาแมวทุก 1 ชั่วโมงนะปกติแล้ว
ก็จะไปหาแมวเค้าจะไปวิ่งเล่นกับแมววิ่ง
เล่นคันนี้บอกนะพ่อแม่กูมานะชอบเล่นได้
แม้ว่าจะวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งมาหาเขา
ก็จะไปวิ่งเล่นกับแมวถึง
น่าจะถึง
18:40 นโมง 40 ก็จบเดี๋ยวชั่วโมงประมาณ
40 นาที
ได้ซึ้งของวง 40 มาแสดงแล้ว
activity เยอะนะติ๊กติง
โค้กกลัวเบื่อใช่ไหมเราต้องใช้ชีวิต
เหมือนเดิมทุกวันให้หา 6:40 เสร็จแล้วสี
ฟ้าก็จะเล่นเกมกับน้องสาวกูว่ามีน้องนะ
นี่เป็นผู้หญิงน้องสาวพระอายุ 20
ฟ้าอายุ 26 ใช่มั้ยน้องสาวก็อายุประมาณ 20
น้องสาวฟ้าเนี่ยเอาเล่นเกมนะคะจะมีอยู่
เกมนึงที่ฟ้าชอบเล่นกับน้องสาวมากว่าจะ
เล่นเกมกับน้องสาวจนถึง
20:00 นอ่ะแต่ชั่วโมงกว่าๆ 1 ชั่วโมง
กว่าๆถึง 20:00 น 20:00 นจะไปกินข้าวค่ะ
คือหญิงเรื่องนี้บ้างคะกูไปกลัวเหมือน
เดิมต้องเลือกหรอจะกินอะไร
สองทุ่มก็เลือกอาหารไว้แล้วค่ะนักเรียนนะ
พวกคนไทยกินข้าวใช่ไหมอันนี้เป็นข้าว
แล้วก็จะมีกับข้าวค่ะกับข้าวกับข้าวเอ่อ 9
กับข้าวคือ
มีเป็นข้าวเมื่อจะกินไข่เจียว
มาแล้วนะข้าวไข่เจียวมันต้องมีไข่เจียวนะ
คะไข่เจียวใช่ไหมใครเที่ยวเนี่ยเนี่ยฝาคน
เรื่องอาหารไว้ก็คืออาหารที่เค้ากินได้
ทุกวันไม่เบื่ออันนี้คือไก่เดียวเนื้อไข่
เกี่ยวนะฮะแล้วก็มีต้มยำ
ต้มยำกุ้งก็ได้อ้ะต้องยำกุ้งมีไข่เจียวมี
ต้มยำกุ้งมีผัดกระเพรา
เนื้อจังเลยตอนเย็นเนี่ยวันนี้อาหารเยอะ
อ่ะปกติแล้วนะแล้วก็มี
อะไรอีกอย่างนึงก็ได้นะอะไรก็ได้อย่าง
หนึ่งนะว่ากินอะไรก็ได้นั่นแหละก็กิน
อาหารนะฮะเสร็จแล้วหลังจากกินข้าวเสร็จ
กินข้าวเรื่องถึงประมาณ
9:00 นค่ะมันคือว่ากินไม่นานนะคิดว่าน่า
จะถ้า
20:00 น 40 น
มันก็จะคุยกับเพื่อนนานก็จะมีโทรศัพท์ใช่
ไหมโทรศัพท์คุยโทรศัพท์คุยเรื่อยๆโดย
โทรศัพท์กับเพื่อนอาจจะเล่นเกมกันคุยกัน
หรือว่าอัพเดทชีวิตกันนะคะจนถึง
เวลาไทยนะคะ
ไม่ตอนแรกคิดว่าจนถึงตี 2 ตกใจนะคะก็มี
ถึงนะเอาเหรอใช่ไปคิดว่าอาจจะประมาณ
เที่ยงคืน
32  1 ประมาณ 2 ชั่วโมง
2 ชั่วโมง
ช่วย 2 ทุ่ม 3 ทุ่มนะใช่ๆเอ่อใช่ผิดผิดๆ
สองทุ่มเกือบ 4 ชั่วโมง
4 ชั่วโมงแสดงว่าจะนอนค่ะค่ะ
นอนๆก็
นั่นแหละจบแล้วค่ะ 1 วันของครูฟ้า
ละเอียดว่ามีเวลาเวลากี่โมงกี่โมงกี่โมง
ใช่หนึ่งวันของครูฟ้านะต้องทำเหมือนเดิม
ทุกวันครูก็ทำแบบนี้
จะเลือกแล้วว่าแบบนี้กูฟ้าจะมีความสุข
เพื่ออะไรมีความสุขใช่อยู่กับเพื่อนอยู่
กับแม่นะคะอยู่กับแล้วก็ครอบครัวส่ง L
หวยต้องมีความสุขตัวแค่นี้ล่ะผู้หญิงล่ะ
ไม่มีครูหญิงอยู่ในนั้นเลยอ่ะอ่ะยังไม่
ละเอียดเหมือนครูฟ้าแล้วกันนะคะเพราะว่า
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าถ้าละเอียดเดี๋ยวกูฟ้าเนี่ย
มันอาจจะเบื่อปุ๋ยเราผู้หญิงทำอะไรจะแบ่ง
เป็นตอนเช้า
9:00 นจะเลือกตื่น 9:00 นนะคะแต่เก้าโมง
เดี่ยหรือถึง
12:30 น
ช่วงช่วงเช้าก็ไม่ถึงกับเป็นเช้าร้อนเช้า
จนถึงกลางวัน
ทำงานอันนี้จะทำงาน
อ่ะทำงาน
จะได้ดูไม่เหมือนกูฟ้านะทำงานใช่ไหมมี
คอมพิวเตอร์
ทำงานมาหาอ้าย
12:30 จนถึง
[เพลง]
กี่โมง
14:00 น
กิน
กินผู้หญิงขึ้นกี่ชั่วโมงเนี่ย
1 ชั่วโมงครึ่งกินนานนะอ่อนเท่ากันใช่
ไหมเออๆกันนะไม่สบาย 2 สมัยก็จะเป็นช่วง
กลางวันจนไปถึง
18:00 น
18:00 นทำอะไรกินสมัยกินมีอาหารละอะไรก็
ได้นะคะ 6 โมงเย็นก็จะเป็นมีคอมพิวเตอร์
เหมือนกัน
แต่ว่าไม่ทำงานอันนี้ก็จะเป็นเวลาว่างดู
YouTube ดูซีรีส์รู้หลังน้อผู้หญิงดู
หนังกี่ชั่วโมงเนี่ย
ก็สิมันผีไม่นอน
4 ชั่วโมงพ่อกูฝันเลยนะแล้วก็
18:00 นจนถึงประมาณ 20:00 นถึงจะทำอะไร
เป็นเวลากินนะคะกินอาหารเย็นๆ 1  2
ชั่วโมง
วิ่งฉิวแล้วนะเอ่อ
[เพลง]
หัวหินหิวมากๆ
เข้า 8:00 น
จนถึง
9:00 นทำอะไรกิน
ร้อน
อันนี้เขาจะไม่ได้นอนอย่างเดียวน้องผู้
หญิงก็ไม่ได้นอนเร็วขนาดนั้นนะคะนักเรียน
ก็อยู่ทำไมเค้านะเอ้ออ้ะเราก็เตียงร้อน
ง่ายใช่ไหมก็จะเป็นนอนฟัง
ฟังอย่างไรก็สวยครูฟ้าเล่านิทานอย่างนี้
ดีจนมาวินเจ้าหญิงอินทราซไรก็นอนฟังแล้ว
ก็หลับแล้วก็ตื่นมา
ช่วงเช้าก็ทำงานกับกินค่ะช่วงบ่ายก็ไป
เวลาพักผ่อนดูซีรีส์ดู YouTube แล้วก็กิน
ฮือผู้หญิงนี่มีเธอร์บุ๊คนะคะ
ไม่มีไม่มีโทรศัพท์นี่ไงคุยก็เลยคิดว่า
ถ้าชีวิตผู้หญิงต้องเป็นเหมือนเดิมทุกวัน
ทุกวันผู้หญิงขอทำงานตอนเช้าทำงานให้
เสร็จแล้วทั้งวันจะรู้สึกเราสบาย
ในของความไม่มีทำงานเลยนะพระฟ้าเลือกได้
เนี่ยก็ไม่ถึงอย่าง
เปรี้ยงอยู่กับแมวนะเฮ้ยอยู่กับแม่จริงๆ
กูฟ้าอยากจะบอกว่าอ๋ออ๋อขอ 24 ชั่วโมงของ
ครูฟ้าอยู่กับแมวแมวได้ไหมพอแล้วตาอันนี้
ก็จะเป็นแบบงานเราสระถ้าเราต้องมีชีวิต
เหมือนเดิมทุกวันทุกวันก็จะเป็นชีวิตที่
เราสองคนเลือกนะคะว่าอยากจะให้มันเป็นยัง
ไงเนาะแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้เนี่ยผู้หญิงกับฟ้า
ก็ไปก่อนนะคะเดี๋ยวกูเค้าจะไปเล่นกับแมว
แล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอน่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะก็อย่า